BJ starts us off in Pikeville Kentucky
hi BJ how are you hey Dave how are you
better than I deserve sir what's up in
your world so I have been making around
seven to ten thousand dollars a year and
Clubman going to school
oh and so now I will be making
considerably more than that I had
questions like where to start
okay how much are you gonna be making
now um 110 thousand I love it when a
plan comes together
what's your degree in dude pharmacy good
for you way to go man congratulations
well and so here we go it's all this
hard work has paid off now we're going
to cash some checks and prove it good
good for you
okay well we teach people to walk up a
series of seven steps to become wealthy
okay and for that matter to manage their
wealth and we take them through a
process have you ever heard of any of
that uh I have and I've been in the
process of maybe ordering a book or two
and reading about about this okay of
ours yes okay good because that would be
the only place you should should find
the baby steps since I invented them but
anyway so yeah but I'll give you a copy
if you haven't ordered it yet a copy of
the book the Total Money Makeover which
walks you through this all right baby
step one is quickly save a thousand
dollars do you have any money saved no
okay
your first thing you do is I want you
set aside thousand dollars is a little
starter rainy day fund a beginner rainy
day fund it's not a fully funded but
it's a starting place the second thing
is you're graduating from school I'm
taking you're taking a pharmacy job are
you moving
I am currently renting are you staying
in the city or have you already moved
out a college town and move to the neck
up yeah okay so you're all set up and
you're renting then in your new job yeah
good good okay so we don't have to have
any money for any of that that's all
underway you're going to do a written
budget every month giving every dollar
an assignment every dollar a mission
and you can use a free online budgeting
tool called every dollar calm it'll help
you do that on your iPhone or on your
computer
and you lay out your budget giving every
dollar an assignment when you've gotten
that then the second thing we're going
to do after the thousand dollars is
we're going to pay off any debt we have
other than a home you're renting you
don't have a home
what other debt do you have other than
that I have about two hundred thousand
dollars in student loan debt
ouch yep well we heard the good news and
early now we get the bad news yeah
you've got a really big hole that you're
in the good news is you've got a good
size shovel to dig out and you're used
to living like a broke person yeah so I
don't have to adjust your lifestyle much
keep living like a broke person what is
the least possible you think you can
live on annually I mean live like a
college student
annually 30 $40,000 okay well let's just
translate that to 50,000 towards the
student loan debt it takes you four
years to get out right okay because you
got paid taxes on this hundred and ten
also yeah so we pay taxes on it we throw
a 50k at the student loan debt that's
forty two hundred forty three hundred
dollars a month okay for four years and
then your debt free that's your first
goal once you've done that after you got
the thousand dollars you do that then
when you're debt-free you build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses then and only then do you talk
about buying a house okay you rent
you're broke and you get yourself out of
broke land the good news is you got a
great income bad news is you've got a
dadgum huge ticket to punch here yeah
beans and rice rice and beans take all
the OT you can get any butt jobs you can
pick up work in weekend er doing
dispensary or whatever you can do you
pick up another 15 20 grand you get out
that much faster I'd like to see you get
out in three years my numbers right now
are saying four but if you can create
some extra income you could get out in
three okay and you might be able to do
that it shop around a little bit I mean
you do have this nice degree in this
nice designation and you passed your
boards or whatever at this point so
that's what I would do I'm going to lean
into these student loans and attack them
like they're the enemy of my future
because they are
attack them like they're the enemy of
your future because they are live on
nothing where all your broke friends are
making fun of you live like a college
student six seven eight ten twelve
thousand dollars a years how you been
living you kick that up to thirty you
just doubled your lifestyle live on
nothing and pay these things off as fast
as you can
that's the highest and the shortest
distance between where you are today and
becoming very very wealthy because if I
can put you out there three or four
years from now and you're making 110 250
by then and you have no debt you're
going to be able to build wealth like
unbelievably fast you're going to have a
great life you really are but only if
you have the discipline to clean this
mess up and you clean it up quickly very
quickly hey you guys Rachael Cruz here
hope you're enjoying the Dave Ramsey
show and did you know that I have my
very own YouTube channel yes that's
right kind of better
Dave Ramsey Channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you